hello freak [ __ ] I became a fan of
yours when I watched you on with what
the [ __ ] is his name the CNN here's
Morgan oh that was glorious hey when you
went after him dissent with the Sandy
Hook thing like right away immediately
like it was just glorious and you could
tell that he didn't know what to do with
it and he literally said how dare you
which is what I say with people all the
time when I'm joking
yes exactly as one my friend said looked
like he was clutching his pearls he was
really pissed you thought really it was
a two segment interview and during the
break I said to him thanks so much for
having me on and kind of growled at me
he was not a happy camper
yeah well you crushed him and the other
one of my other favorite ones was
Chelsea Handler crushing them where she
was literally talking like you don't
even talked to me in the brake and the
brake you're checking your phone and
checking Twitter and he could tell he
was like oh no he just you know he came
from that weird British tabloid
environment and you found out that it
the company that he worked for did
really creepy [ __ ] like check people's
voicemail yeah hacked in the people's
people who are dead and it gave the
family false hope because they had
checked the voicemail and they found out
that someone checked in they thought oh
maybe she's still alive and then we made
him a host unlike the x-factor and
brought him on Sienna is awesome I just
don't let me get to things all around
why CNN thought that we have this
fascination with British people yes if
you have a British accent we
automatically had 20 points to IQ yeah
they're great for like selling mops late
night and nonstick cookware and I
enjoyed John Oliver I think John Oliver
is great apparently he has a you know a
lot of people think of all British
accents as being the same but he has
like blue-collar British actor but I
don't I can't tell the difference much
except when I'm watching my fair lady or
something well I could tell people from
like Manchester and stuff like that
because they you know they have like
this sort of like way of talking so fast
with all the words kind of pile into
each other but uh yeah Oliver's his uh
his recent one Eddie Bravo got really
matter that the recent one about Alex
Jones is [ __ ] hilarious well you see
it's almost impossible to make something
not funny about Alex Jones no you got to
meet Alex have you met him I don't know
that
given how much I've made fun of him I
realize now yeah he says like a coffee
shirt and started
he might calm down you're a good guy
we're basically on the same team he
would come around if you remember the
Piers Morgan thing happened two nights
after Alex is on Piers Morgan so Allen
appears was like flying high because he
had that whole debate with Alex and Alex
did his shtick and it was really over
the top and he thought I was going to be
like Alex Jones part two is going to be
peers you know succeeds again and Alex
and I could not be more different
no you're very rational and very
reasonable
[Applause]
[Music]